Oh, yeah.
Yeah, that's
So, what
You ask
It did
all of the
question
ask
in it.
answers
prophets
whole
Sallallahu
and
for the
your second
question.
article of the
person may
What
say the
generally, oh, well, you know, maybe he
wrote this himself.
Read it.
Even in English,
no human being could have come up with
this.
And so, it contains in it
all relevant answers to come after. This
is incredible.
One of Allah's names is Al-Hayy.
What is Al-Hayy?
The one who is not only alive or living,
but the provider of life, the essence of
life. He is the essentially
living. He is Subhana Wa Ta'ala, the
source of life itself.
He is alive in himself and he gives all
life to others.
And the Quran is his words.
And so the Quran
has in it that life.
It's almost as if it is still speaking
to us, still interacting with us. It's
not just an innate book. It's still
giving and taking
with people. Subhanallah. Every time you
pick up the Quran and read it mindfully,
thoughtfully,
it is as if you are having a dialogue.
It's as if you are speaking to Allah
[Arabic recitation]
Because the Quran doesn't just have
innate verses. Every verse, it's as if
it is asking of you, taking from you,
and giving to you. That is incredible on
its own.
So Allah says,
after having this book,
Hal yanzuruna
illa an ta'tiyahum al-mala'ikah. What
are they waiting for to believe then?
They already know that this is from
Allah.
But they're not entering Islam still.
They're still not accepting. Why? What
are they waiting for? Are they waiting
for the angels of death to come and
collect their souls?
Are they waiting for the day of judgment
before they stand before Allah Subhana
Wa Ta'ala to argue their case of
negligence?
Or are they waiting
for the most major of the signs of your
Lord?
On that day when the most major
of the signs of your Lord and miracles
and happenings of your Lord take place,
no soul
shall be benefited by its newly found
faith
that it did not have prior to witnessing
these signs.
Nor shall any soul be benefited
by its newly found
deeds and newly found fruits of faith
upon witnessing these miracles.
Because these miracles, these signs are
so compelling
that a person is not believing in
al-ghaib anymore.
It's as if a person is not believing in
the unseen anymore. There's no step of
hope and faith there. It is something
that is undeniable a freight train,
you must accept it.
And so it's not a free will. La ikraha
fi al-din.
Now, we were discussing this verse.
And we mentioned that this verse
primarily
with respect to the major signs of your
Lord that Allah mentions here. So, he
mentions three things. Number one,
death, the angels of death. Number two,
the day of judgment. And number three,
the most major of signs before the day
of judgement. And we mentioned in the
narration
[Arabic recitation]
wasallam in the
wasallam explained this verse to mean
what?
What is the most major of Allah's signs?
The sun rises from the west.
Okay.
Now in that narration he mentions the
sun rising from the west.
There is another narration
also in
where the prophet
comments on this verse as well.
And he mentions three things.
Instead of just the sun rising from the
west, he mentions three things.
Number one, the sun rising from the
west.
Number two, a dab.
And number three, a dajjal.
So a dab
is as Allah
says
In surat al naml
Allah
mentions that
near the day of judgement, one of its
most major signs
is an animal from the earth shall
arise upon people, on humanity.
Will arrive upon humanity.
And speak to them.
And mark them
with their belief or disbelief.
What does that mean?
That means when the animal emerges, we
don't know what kind of animal it is. It
is a dab.
Dab in the Arabic language may it do
Allah Allah a yam she Allah Allah.
A dab is some kind of animal that exists
on top of the earth.
And it will emerge upon humanity and
speak to them.
We don't know if it's a wolf.
If it's a cow, if it's a monkey, we
don't know what it is. Could be
anything, any kind of animal.
But it will emerge. And it will separate
people into two camps, believer and
disbeliever.
And it will mark them.
As believer and disbeliever.
When this dab emerges,
it will mark people as
this is a believer and this is a
disbeliever. And they will have some
sign, some symbol as a result of the
marking of this animal.
Now this will occur after the sun rises
from the west.
Now,
what is
the time of the emergence of a Dajjal? A
Dajjal will emerge before the sun rises
from the west.
Now, there are certain things that have
to happen before a Dajjal emerges.
But when a Dajjal emerges,
he will come across the earth a
rain
pouring and driven by a howling wind.
The prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
described his quickness on the earth
as
Kallai oh oh Kallai Kallai matar
[Arabic recitation]
wind is blowing very hard, how the rain
even kind of hurts when it hits you?
That kind of pouring driven rain a
the fury of a storm, that is the speed
and swiftness with which a Dajjal
will visit the earth.
The Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
in some narrations tells us that a
person will hear
that a Dajjal has emerged in a certain
town
and will hear that he is heading for his
town and before he can even prepare
himself to leave, a Dajjal is at the
gates.
And a Dajjal
will not spare a single town,
city or village
except that he will enter it.
Everyone
except for two cities.
Two cities on this entire earth,
Mecca
and Medina.
Mecca and Medina are the only safeholds
from Al Masih ad-Dajjal's physical
entrance.
Doesn't mean his his news will not enter
Mecca and Medina. Yes, people will hear
about him, people will hear of his
descriptions, hear of things that
happened, rumors will will circulate,
but his physical body
will not enter Mecca and Medina.
You know in the 70s, 80s and 90s a lot
of people that are very
very broad in the liberties that they
take with respect to interpretation
of the prophet's words, they claim that
the computer was a Dajjal.
They said, "You know, one eye, it has
one screen." And made all these
connections. Are there computers in
Mecca and Medina?
Yes.
The prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said in Sahih al-Bukhari
that he saw a Dajjal
and that a Dajjal was a young man
and he was clad in muscle.
His muscles are so dense and so defined
that he has a hunch in his back. Have
you ever seen these kinds of
you know, these kinds of
weightlifters when they become so
muscular, they almost start to have a
hunch at the top of their back?
He says
that his hair
is extremely coarse and extremely curly.
It is It is very
curly, almost to the point of being
nappy.
Right?
And that a Dajjal has two eyes. Doesn't
just have one eye.
Saying referring to a Dajjal as a
cyclops
or referring to a Dajjal in English as
one-eyed is wrong. That is a wrong
interpretation.
Because a Dajjal has two eyes.
It's just that one of them
is deficient.
The Arabs, when they say awar in the
Arabic language, they say awar. He said
a Dajjal, every prophet and messenger
that has come before me
he has warned his people of a Dajjal.
And I I tell you of a description of his
that you cannot conflate or confuse.
Indeed, the Dajjal is
[Arabic recitation]
bi-a'war.
That he will claim to be Allah.
And he will claim to be the Lord of
humanity.
He said, "But he is deficient in one of
his two eyes, his right eye per se.
And indeed, your Lord is not deficient
in either of his eyes, subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
And so,
the Dajjal has two eyes.
But,
one of those eyes,
which is the right eye,
it is swollen to where it is almost
bulging.
The prophet described it as a grape
in a glass of water.
A grape in a glass of water, right? Ka
'inabah at-tafiyah aw at-ta'ishah.
Meaning you know, a grape, I don't
know if you ever but a a grape, it
doesn't sink. Okay? It floats, it's
buoyant. And if you were to put that
grape in a glass of water, the way that
it kind of protrudes out of that water,
this is the way that his eye almost
bulges out.
And in other descriptions, its light
is extinguished.
And in another narration, the light of
his eye ka kawkab ad-durriyal ghabir
is a distant star.
You ever seen, you know, humans,
subhanallah,
why people say that eyes are the
windows to the soul, right? That you can
tell a lot by a person's eyes.
Because the eyes articulate life.
And if you've ever seen someone that's
dead and seen their eyes and their blank
stare, it's almost as if their eyes are
glazed, glazed over,
right? It's there's almost light
that comes out of our eyes. And when a
person dies, that light dims.
So, the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam, he described the light of his
eye
to be a distant star
whose light which its light has been
extinguished.
It is almost
a a tiny light in the center,
almost as if it's far away.
Right?
And so, this is the description of a
dajjal, and he is a young man.
Can we describe a computer with these
descriptions?
Are there computers a young man with
very nappy, curly hair, very muscular to
where he's hunched over to having you
know, one eye correct and one eye
deficient? And written between his eyes,
meaning on his forehead, is kafir.
Kafir, meaning kaf, fa, ra.
In modern Arabic, we write kafir with
four letters.
Kaf, alif, fa, ra.
In
ancient shorthand Arabic, you would
not write the alif. The alif is
understood to be there. So, it'd be kaf,
fa, ra, and the alif is implied.
So, what is written is kafir.
[Arabic recitation]
it
whether they are literate or not.
Whether they are
whether they are lettered or not.
There are certain words that even in
Arabic, the general Muslim
will
be able to read these words. for
instance, the word Allah.
Mhm. Any Muslim, most Muslimin, if
they've ever seen it written, they could
recognize Allah even if they don't know
how to read the Arabic language, right?
Ar-Rahman.
Al-Quran.
Right? And likewise, this is almost a
symbol.
Does the computer have kafir written
between its eyes between on its
forehead?
No. Did Ayatollah Khomeini have it
written on his forehead? Because these
are all claims that were made, right?
you know, did
People to assign this to every
modern phenomenon. Did George Bush Jr.
or Sr. have it written on his forehead?
Was he a young muscular man with with
curly hair almost to the point of nappy?
No.
To dismiss these things as being
symbolic is wrong because the Prophet
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam in the same
narration, he described Musa, he
described Isa, and he described the
Dajjal.
So, we know that Musa is a real person.
Isa is a real person. And Dajjal is a
real person. And really, the ultimate
sign is
Mecca and Medina.
The prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
said that when the Dajjal arrives at
Mecca or Medina, he will find the angels
standing at each and every pathway and
gate to Mecca and Medina with their
swords drawn.
And he will be told to go back. You
can't pass through here.
Now,
one of the questions that were were
mentioned
yesterday and the day before
is
we have all these signs of the day of
judgment, right?
But Allah tells us about the day of
judgment that la ta'tikum
[Arabic recitation]
ta'tikum yani sa' illa baghtah.
Right?
That the day of judgment will only will
will take the people by surprise.
Just because we know that the day of
judgment is eminent doesn't mean that we
won't be surprised when it actually
happens. Imagine with me
that you're in your house
and there are home intruders at your
front door
and they are kicking the door trying to
break in.
You know that they're going to make it
through the door, right?
Correct?
Yeah.
But
when they actually break in that moment,
will you not be surprised?
You'll be surprised even though you're
expecting it.
The prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
said that when the horn is blown,
people, all of society, all of humanity
at that time, it is nothing but damned
souls roaming the earth. Every one of
them knows that the day of judgement is
eminent, the world is falling apart, the
heavens are about to fall and collapse,
and it is any minute now. But when that
horn is blown,
that it will shock people into
motionlessness.
That people will freeze.
You know, fight or flight response.
When a deer,
your headlights hit a deer on the
road, how it freezes, right? This is
what will happen to people. He describes
a man who is selling a piece of fabric,
and a man who is giving the money for
that fabric.
And notice here,
people don't trust each other at that
time. When you When you buy something,
do you buy it this?
Huh? When do you buy it something like
that?
Huh? Okay, 1 2 3.
Right? When do you buy something like
that?
When we don't trust each other.
So, this man will extend The merchant
will extend the piece of fabric to hand
it. The other man will extend the money
to give, and they will freeze in place.
A man will be with his livestock on his
way to Medina. Medina will be in ruins.
The prophet described even his masjid
that foxes will be urinating by where
the where the minbar once stood.
And that it'll just be wild animals that
live in the masjid.
No one is there.
And that a man shepherd will be herding
his flock into Medina.
And he'll be calling his flock and
fighting with them, and the animals are
acting wild beasts. They're not
taking direction.
Right? And then suddenly, the horn of
the day of judgement will blow.
And he will freeze in place.
We will continue this inshallah ta'ala
in our coming night.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah